hi everyone hope you're having a great
weekend it's about to get better welcome
to one nation i'm brian kilmeade the
traditional in social media up until
2020 has decided what is important and
what isn't in this country there was
always an unspoken compact between
america and their journalists but
currently that compact is busted apart
for example as big a scandal as the
black lives matter money trail is as big
a scandal as the hunter biden saga
remains as big a scandal as the findings
of the dorm probe are traditional and
social media basically are ignoring them
i believe that the media's choice to
ignore these stories of that magnitude
is even more concerning than the corrupt
stories and practices themselves that
need to be investigated in the first
place i'll give you some perspective
can you imagine if the media ignored the
watergate scandal that brought nixon
down can you imagine if the monica
lewinsky bill clinton's saga was never
in the paper and the abu grey prison
abuse in iraq was simply ignored or the
miley massacre during the vietnam war we
covered that or the iran contra affair
during the second term of the ronald
reagan administration remember that so
what is the solution now
maybe this could be the start tesla's
elon musk took a majority stake in
twitter what's the big deal well musk
has hinted at shaking up the social
media industry before and now he's uh he
has that platform and he's in control
he's on the board and he is the biggest
shareholder we know social media goes
out of its way to block the truth that
they don't like or they think might be
not worth us knowing that's their
decision freeing up mainstream sources
to totally ignore it as well they were
tight they will won
so can musk be the reality check the
media needs to cover things more fairly
could they lead twitter and then force
the other big tech outlets to follow his
lead piecing back together that trust
that was blasted apart over the last few
years my fingers are crossed the answer
is yes hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now